Seriously, we're leaving
in five minutes.
Okay, well that's exactly how
long it takes me to get ready.
To the first Friday night
in our first London house.
Wooo! Yes!
This girl is my childhood
sweetheart.
Birdy?
Jesus Christ!
Hi.
Why do you have so many
tiny towels?
They're not tiny towels,
they're face cloths.
Who's it from?
Who do you think?
Birdy's got a boyfriend.
Nothing will change, Maggie.
That's only a thing people say
when everything's changing.
You have always been my
most important person.
I don't know if we should be
that to each other anymore.
We're in this grubby,
golden phase of life that is so short lived.
Sorry I want to live before I die.